you're running a successful
company and it's just interesting
because my mind has been in that space
of uh potentially just being one of the
millions other
entrepreneurs uh what's your advice
on uh how to build a successful startup
how to build a successful company
i think that one thing i i do like and
it might be a particular thing about
america but like
there is something about like playing
tell people what you
really want to happen in the world like
don't
stop it it's not it's not gonna make it
um like if you're asking someone to
invest in your company
don't say i think maybe one day we might
make a million dollars
um when you actually believe something
else
you actually believe you're actually
more optimistic but you're
toning down your optimism because you
want to appear
um like low risk
but actually it's super high risk if
your company becomes mediocre
because no one wants to work a mediocre
company no one wants to invest in media
so you should play the real game um and
obviously this doesn't apply to all
businesses but if you play a venture
back
startup kind of game like play for keeps
play to win
go big um and it's very hard to do that
i've always feel like um
i yeah i start you can start narrowing
narrowing your focus because
10 people are telling you you know you
got to care about this
boring thing that won't matter five
years from now and
you should push back and do the real
play the real game
to be bold so both i mean there's a
there's an interesting duality there so
there's
the way you speak to other people about
like your plans
and what you are like privately just
in in your own mind and maybe it's
connected with what you were saying
about yeah sincerity as well
like if you if you appear to be
sincerely optimistic
about something that's big or crazy
it's putting yourself up to be kind of
like ridiculed or something yes
and so if you say my my mission is to um
yeah go to mars it's just so bonkers
that uh
it's hard to say it is but uh
uh one powerful thing just like you said
is if you say it and you believe it
then actually amazing people uh
come and work with you exactly it's not
just skill but the
the dreams there's something about
optimism that
uh like that fire that you have when
you're optimistic of
actually having the hope of building
something totally cool something totally
new
that when those people get in a room
together like they can actually do it
yeah uh yeah there's yeah there's
that's uh and also makes life really fun
when you're
in that room so all that together uh
ultimately i don't know that's what
makes this crazy ride of a startup
really
uh look fun and elon is an example of a
person who succeeded at that
there's not many other inspiring figures
which is sad
i used to be a google and there's uh
there's something that happens that
sometimes when the company grows
bigger and bigger and bigger where that
kind of ambition kind of quiets down a
little bit
yeah you know google had this ambition
still does of making the world's
information accessible to everyone
and i remember i don't know that's
beautiful
i i still love that dream of
that you know they used to scan books
but just in every way possible make the
world's information
accessible same with wikipedia every
time i open up wikipedia
um i'm just awe
inspired by how awesome humans are man
and creating this together i don't know
what the meetings are over there but
they it's just beautiful like what
they've created is
is incredible and i'd love to be able to
be part of something like that
and you're right for that you have to be
bold and there's
and strange to me also i think you're
right that there's how many boring
companies there are
right something i talk about especially
in fintech it's like
why am i excited about this is so lame
like what is this isn't even like
important even if you succeed this is
going to be like
terrible yeah this is not good um and
it's just strange how
people can kind of get fake enthusiastic
about like boring ideas
yeah when there's so many bigger ideas
that
um yeah i mean you read these things
like this company raises money and it's
just like that's a lot of money for the
worst idea i've ever heard
some ideas are uh really big so like i
worked on autonomous vehicles quite a
bit
and there's so many ways in which you
can present that idea to yourself to the
team you work with
to just yeah like to yourself when
you're quietly looking in the mirror in
the morning
that's really boring or really exciting
like if you're really ambitious with
autonomous vehicles
there it it changes the nature of like
human robot
interaction it's changing the nature of
how we move forget money if you get all
that stuff it changes like everything
about robotics and ai machine learning
it changes everything about
manufacturing i mean the cars that
transportation is so fundamentally
connected to cars and if that changes
it you're changing the fabric of society
of movies of
everything and if you go bold and take
risks and go
be willing to go bankrupt with your
company
as opposed to cautiously you could you
could really change the world and it's
so sad for me to see all these
autonomous companies
autonomous vehicle companies they're
like really more focused about
fundraising and kind of like smoke and
mirrors they're really afraid they're
the the entirety of their marketing is
grounded in fear
and presenting enough smoke to where
they keep raising funds so they
can cautiously use technology of a
previous decade or previous two decades
to kind of test vehicles here and there
as opposed to do
crazy things in bold and go huge at
scale
to huge data collection i mean
yeah so that's just an example like the
idea can be big but if you don't allow
yourself
to take that idea and think really big
with it
then you're not going to make anything
happen
you